so you may be thinking to yourself is it
time to finally upgrade to a Mac Studio
I've got a MacBook Pro M1 Max or M2 Max
for that matter but should I get the
studio now that has an M2 Ultra chip or
should I just do with a MacBook Pro both
are great machines I'm going to give you
five reasons why you should be
considering the Mac Studio depending on
your work needs number one size if
you're worried about portability do not
be this machine is very small I've never
used a Max studio before until the M2
Ultra and M2 Max and I was shocked at
the size of this thing I mean we're used
to seeing PC towers with you know RGB
lighting and fans and they just like it
looks like it's out of a you know some
sort of server room right I mean they
look cool but they take up a lot of
space on a desk now if you're in a
gaming great those are you need those
but if you're into content creation
this Mac Studio N2 Ultra
is this
you can put into them back
you can take it onto a train if you're
like working in the city you want to go
home and work you can do that as long as
you've got a display at home
you're free to go
you want to travel across the country
you can do it as long as the place
you're going to has a display that you
can plug into you're good
it's portable it's not that heavy now
the M2 Max version is lighter than the
M2 Ultra
but it's actually it's quite like
considering how much power this machine
has next up power the M2 Ultra is the
creme de La Creme when it comes to power
out of these M series chipsets it's
freaking amazing now here's the thing
with the power depending on your Usage
Now if you are a graphic designer if
you're doing like 3D animation Cinema 4D
After Effects and this is where you live
in and you're doing AK video you're
doing rendering compositing all that
kind of stuff Ultras that's the
playground you want to be in right now
the M2 Max can do a lot of that
definitely can but the M2 Ultra will be
shockingly good now you're not going to
always see it all the time in its most
powerful form you know day-to-day tasks
the M2 Max and the M2 Ultra are
relatively the same now I've done a
video on my channel and that'll be going
more in depth with cinnamon gear and
everything else
but it's 30 faster on average than the
M1 Ultra for production houses that are
on a time crunch 30 faster means a lot
it means a lot you can do more multitask
more and give you 30 more power
that's worthy investment now for the
average person out there you probably
just stick with an M2 Max and then that
will be more than adequate for you
Ultra is where it shines and if you have
the means to buy an ultra do so because
this computer will last you a number of
years and I'll talk about that later on
next is ports now one of my biggest
issues with a lot of Apple's Pro laptops
the MacBook Pro especially is the lack
of ports now even though the MacBook Pro
has more ports on the MacBook Air you
know for someone like me who's a content
creator who has an external audio device
that I'm recording to I have card
readers external storage devices I'm
running out of ports plus a display
right the Mac Studio gives you more
ports USBC USB a thunderbolt 4 card
readers you have everything inside this
machine so if you need these things
especially because you're creating a lot
of content you have external drives that
you need to have access to card readers
you need access to audio devices like I
do they need access to this is where the
Mac Studio shines it has the ports you
need could it use more ports we could
always use more ports but it's got
enough for me and a lot and enough for
most people out there that I think that
are going to be using this for
professional reasons and I'm very happy
to be able to use this and not have to
like take things out plug things in and
out just to actually maximize my content
here culture we've tested plenty of
chairs but Secret Life gaming chairs
remain one of our favorites whether it's
for work or play they feel great to lean
back against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head
and back
to the arms and even something for your
butt this makes a four man function
helps the Titan Evo 2020 to deliver the
best seating experience like no other
for more information check out
secretlab.co next let's talk about
monitors you need more monitors than one
well the Mac Studio M2 Ultra can handle
eight eight K resolution 240 hertz
refresh rate it can handle the eight
displays the unit 8 display as well as
your Bruce Wayne in the Batcave you
probably don't all the time maybe some
people do but Apple says well if you are
Bruce Wayne
you can put this in the Batcave and
that's all you need I'm Batman pretty
damn amazing right I'm just using one
Studio display love it awesome and last
but not least future proofing Apple has
really come a long way with their own
silicone right the M1 M1 Max M1 Ultra
freaking phenomenon the M2 series is
what really shines
and I know Apple's going to come out
with an M3 and 4 M5 they always will
I can safely say the M2 Ultra
is going to be a machine that he's going
to be with you for a few years I mean
the M1 Ultra you could say that as well
but the M2 Ultra with more RAM inside of
it now I mean the more configurations
you can do with this how powerful this
machine is
a lot of pros and content creators out
there the ultra will be the only
computer you need for the next three
years
I mean I'm putting money on that I don't
know how much but I'm putting money on
that
seriously it is because we're not really
I mean 8K we're seeing it more into Pro
streamer cameras we're seeing more
coming to play but it's not mainstream
as of yet when it becomes mainstream let
me tell you something this thing edits
ink like it's HD
no stuttering nothing Apple quotes 22
streams and prores
I was doing 30 streams with red 8K raw
footage and he was still playing
smoothly that's how powerful this
machine is it is future proof so if
you're worried about your investment
going to waste without after a year or
so do not be this machine is going to
last you and personally for me if I
could afford an M2 Ultra I would get it
because
I'm done I can sit back I can edit
anything I need to edit for YouTube or
for whatever work Tick Tock Instagram
and I ain't got nothing to worry about
so with that said those are five reasons
why you should consider the Mac Studio
M2 Ultra and M2 Max now the M2 Max is
gonna be fine for most people out there
I would say 85 percent of people out
there the M2 Max is more than adequate
just get enough RAM that is the key to
this machine by extra round you can't
put in it afterwards you've got to buy
it as when you order it but do that
you're gonna be fine the M2 Ultra is for
the pros out there that need this for
their living they need faster rendering
faster you know for animations in Cinema
4D everything that you need that's where
the ultra comes into play it's overkill
for most but for the pros that need it
it's freaking awesome anyway guys if you
like this video subscribe to the channel
hit that like button as well if you want
to see more of our laptop reviews from
Apple especially check them out right
here
[Music]